Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Zutritt zum Podcast gibt es jetzt nur noch über LNP-ID übrigens.
Ich bin nicht mehr dabei.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 454 vom 24. Februar 2023.
Für die Freunde der Art und
Weise die Jahreszahl sozusagen heute mal ganz exklusiv am Jahrestag des Beginns
der Ukraine des Ukraine Krieges finden wir uns erneut zusammen wir beide hallo
Linus hallo Tim ich wollte nur sagen 23
an den 24 Das ist der Februar, die 24 ist keine Träne.
Jetzt muss ich wieder mit dem Primmzahler gucken.
Heute achten wir darauf, dass alles teilbar ist, damit wir das dann auch noch
auf Twitter geteilt bekommen, weil ich hab gehört, Primmzahlen darf man jetzt auch nicht mehr posten.
Das ist das größte Thema, was wir bei LogFood jetzt jeweils hatten.
Das bricht alle Rekorde auf jeden Fall. Das ist der Clickbait,
den wir alle schon immer haben wollten.
Wollten. So läuft das. Ja, ja, genau. Aber jetzt demnächst wird halt auch der
Zugang zum Podcast schwieriger, weil nur noch mit LNP-ID, das führen wir jetzt ein.
Man muss sich dann irgendwie mit einem Zeugnis aus der ersten Klasse von seiner
Grundschule irgendwie identifizieren, per Fax.
Und dann darf man auch wieder die Podcast runterladen.
Ja, dann machen wir das. Dann wird er gefaxt in Fax-Abrufdienst.
Genau, das wäre auch nochmal von... Ace64, dann wird er nochmal gefaxt. Okay.
Ich bin schon ein bisschen albern.
Wir sind wieder albern, ja.
Es gibt wieder Shirts. Hört mir auf, es meldeten sich schon Leute,
dass ihre Bestellungen gecancelt wurden. Ja. Was war da wieder los?
Das war wohl eher ein Unfall. Also es gab eine Rohwaren-Shortage,
die dazu führte, dass dann die Dinger automatisch ausgelistet wurden.
Und das führte wohl leider in manchen Fällen auch dazu, dass irgendwelche Bestellungen
dann ausgetimt sind. Und das tut uns sehr leid. Da konnten wir leider nichts dafür.
Hoffentlich ist es jetzt wieder vorbei. Jetzt sollte wieder alles verfügbar sein.
Also tolle Einhorn-Standarte ist wieder im Angebot und demnächst gibt es dann
auch noch Beutelchen auf Wunsch von Hörerinnen und Hörern.
Das kann ich überhaupt nicht verstehen.
Wieso?
Es ist also, wer hat, also Hand aufs Herz, Tim.
Hast du einen YouTube-Beutel zu Hause?
Mehrere.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, dass es jemanden gibt, der keinen hat?
Ganz vorsichtige Frage. Ich
glaube, das ist ein Produkt, wo ich den Markt jetzt für erschöpft halte.
Wirklich? Also ich habe große, breite Verwendung für jute Beutel.
Ich habe im Zweifelsfall immer nicht genug...
Fun fact bringen oder was?
Nö, so was weiß ich. Wenn ich auf Reisen gehe, habe ich immer zwei,
drei dabei, damit ich irgendwo auch meine schmutzige Wäsche irgendwie im Koffer
verstauen kann, die dann nochmal separiert ist.
Ja, aber dann nimmt man doch keinen LNP Einhornbeutel.
Nein, dann nimmt man die von Aldi, aber dann hat man halt keine.
Und deswegen, wenn du dann halt auch mal, das ist ja dann, sagen wir mal,
auch eben so das gezielte Shoppen.
Also man geht dann sozusagen aus und macht seinen Samstag Nachmittag Spaziergang
in der Shopping Mall. Und dann will man natürlich auch was hermachen, nicht wahr? Und was?
In der Shopping Mall? Du gehst in eine Shopping Mall?
Nein, ich nicht. Ich gehe überhaupt nie shoppen, aber es sind Leute, die tun so etwas.
Ja gut, du kannst aber auch mal für die Familie einkaufen, Tim.
Ich...
Du könntest dich ruhig mal beteiligen an den...
Ich? An den Einkäufen. Ich bin... Ja, ich bin Chef-Einkäufer, kann ich dir sagen.
Ja, aber dann wiederum reicht doch nicht so ein Jutebeutel aus.
Ist ja nicht für mich... Ist ja sozusagen... Also wie auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall, ich mach das ja nur on demand. Also ich lass mich ja sozusagen...
Einkäufe. Ich höre ja auch viel weg.
Nein, nein, nein. Weiß, also diese Beute, die sind aus mir nicht erkennbaren Gründen der Renner.
Wir haben die ja auch beim Congress,
habe ich mal auf Wunsch von Daniel, den hier so, die Beute, dann haben wir die
gemacht mit Chaosknoten, mit Tastaturstern, mit Pesthörnchen und so.
Die waren auch sofort weg.
Die hatten aber auch einen einfachen Deal, weil das war beim Camp, mein ich, beim Camp 19.
Und deren Deal war einfach. Kommt jemand, kauft zwei Produkte und dann haben sie gesagt, Tüte.
Das war easy. Das war einfach. Ja gut, also ich bin, ja wenn ihr meint,
ich glaube das ist ein Produkt was...
Was sich erschöpft. Und übrigens auch hier kleine Anekdote, weil man bei uns
ja so wenig lernt im Podcast.
Ich habe vor längerer Zeit so ein, ich weiß gar nicht, ob das ein Artikel war
oder ein Podcast, wo Sie der Frage nachgegangen sind, ob man wirklich der Umwelt
was Gutes tut, wenn man sich so ein Beutel zulegt.
So ein gute Beutel. Und da haben Sie mal irgendwie Abnutzung,
Einkäufe und so weiter gegengerechnet, sind davon ausgegangen,
dass du eben entweder jedes Mal dir so eine Feinplastiktüte geben lässt,
die dann nachher irgendwie in alle Einzelteile zerlegt im Magen irgendeiner Schildkröte landet,
weil das ja alles als Feinplastik im Meer landet, oder so ein Baumwollbeutel nimmst.
Und es war tatsächlich so, dass der Baumwollbeutel, den musst du wirklich so
richtig bis zum Ende seiner Lebenszeit, dann schafft er das am Ende weniger
Schaden anzurichten als so eine Plastiktüte, was jetzt Klima angeht.
Aber ich, ich, also kauft ruhig.
Klima, ja gut, aber nicht was, was Umweltverschmutzung betrifft.
Also, ich meine, jeglicher Konsum ist im Prinzip ein Problem.
Wir können uns jetzt nur im Rahmen der besseren Lösungen bewegen.
Deswegen haben wir kleine Beutel, damit ihr nicht so viel kauft.
Das macht die Beutel nicht schlecht. Sollen die ruhig mal für uns Werbung laufen?
Ist doch in Ordnung. So, genug von unseren Kapitänen zu sprechen.
Aber den machen wir schwarz, den Beutel, nicht das, weil ich finde,
weil sich bei diesen Weißen immer so ein bisschen, die werden immer so...
Wo denkst du hin? natürlich schwarz.
Das ist doch auch keine Grußküste.
Die wiederum, die schwarzen Beute.
Da erinnerst du deine Meinung jetzt komplett.
Den schwarzen könnte ich noch gebrauchen.
Ich hab nur drei.
Siehst du mal. Einen mit einem Pesthörnchen, einen mit einem Chaosknoten und
einen mit einem Tastaturstern.
Siehst du mal. Geht noch einer. Collect all four.
So, was haben wir noch? Was ist das schon?
Primzahlthematik hat jetzt, also da werden eigene Podcasts so aufgenommen.
Da gibt es tatsächlich, ich habe erst gedacht, ach herrje, jetzt nehmen sie
schon Podcasts auf und empfehlen die hier.
Aber war tatsächlich, habe ich mit Interesse gehört, hat jemand erklärt,
warum eins keine Primzahl ist und was das für Konsequenzen hätte.
Und es ist auch, muss ich tatsächlich zugeben, eine späte Freude in meinem Leben.
Das ist mathematische Definitionswesen.
Also warum ist Zahl hoch 0, 1 und nicht was anderes? Ne, Zahl hoch 1, 0? Wie auch immer.
In letzter Zeit habe ich mir da ab und zu so ein paar Herleitungen mal durchgelesen.
Das war immer irgendwie ganz schön.
Seitdem ich im Abitur eh gleich im C-Quadrat herleiten musste,
hatte ich mit Herleitungen abgeschlossen.
Alles hoch 0 ist 1.
Genau und dann wurde, da war dann irgendwie eine schöne Erklärung,
warum das so sein muss. Ja, das also, das klar muss ja auch so sein.
Man denkt immer, dass wir alles irgendwie gewaltsam hergeleitet haben,
aber das macht dann alles Sinn und das war in diesem Podcast ganz schön erklärt.
Wer darauf steht, bitte zukünftig dann dort diskutieren.
Eigenraum-Podcast. Ausgabe Nummer 14, Definitionssache.
Da werden wir explizit sogar verlinkt.
Sehr schön. Ja, da werden wir auch zitiert. Wir haben einfach Ausschnitte aus
unserer Sendung genommen.
Da habe ich schon einen Anwalt Bescheid gesagt. Raubmord-Kopierer.
Kommen wir gleich auch noch mal zu.
Und dann wurde sehr viel diskutiert. Die Bund-ID, das wurde breit diskutiert.
Da haben dann auch, ich glaube, aus jedem Bundesland jemand gesagt,
wieder die Studiengebührenlage gerade ist und warum das in seiner spezifischen
oder ihrer spezifischen Situation mit der Erstattung jetzt geht oder nicht,
weil in der jeweiligen Das-Master-Studium kann man wiederum von der Steuer absetzen.
Also das ist auch abschließend der Örtat, aber der wichtigste Kommentar war
eher so beiläufig und zwar kommentierte, Sekunde, Name, ja, setzte sich damit auseinander, dass
dass das eine tatsächliche Problem doch eigentlich ist, dass man sehr viele Möglichkeiten hat.
Von der man wählen kann. Das Wandton, der dann abschließt sein Kommentar mit noch am Rande.
Da du die Bund-ID nicht kanntest, freut es dich sicher zu hören,
dass es auch eine Bayern-ID gibt.
Und damit glaube ich, ist das Thema auch zu Ende diskutiert.
Also das ist einfach ja genau, genau das. Also die Frage ist,
was gibt es eigentlich mehr?
Das ist eine interessante Frage. Gibt es eigentlich mehr?
Es gibt nicht nur die Bayern-ID, sondern es gibt dazu natürlich das Bayern-Portal,
da kannst du dich darüber informieren. Dann gibt es natürlich auch noch die Bayern-App.
Davon bin ich jetzt ausgegangen. Aber die Frage, die ich mir stelle,
ist, kann ich dann mit der Bayern ID, irgendwie mit Bavaria One, dann fliegen?
Kennen Sie noch Bavaria One?
Das war irgendwie das Mondprogramm von Markus Söder.
Ich lese gerade, die Bayern ID hat aber auch schon End of Life.
Die Bayern ID, ne, Entschuldigung, ne, stimmt gar nicht. Es gab nur ein Bayern ID Unternehmenskonto.
Das wurde im Dezember 22 zugunsten des bundeseinheitlichen Mein-Unternehmenskonto
auf Elster Basis deaktiviert.
Mit Ihrem Elster Unternehmenskonto können Sie bundesweit Ihren Onlineverfahren
für Ihr Unternehmen durchführen und erhalten Ihre digitalen Nachrichten wie
gewohnt in Ihr Postfach. Wie gewohnt.
Und wie mit der Bayern ID kann ich nicht bundesweit?
Offensichtlich nicht, nur bayernweit. Aber ist ja interessant,
wieso habe ich denn so was noch nicht? Ein älster Unternehmenskonto.
Weil du kein Unternehmen hast. Schön finde ich dieses, erhalten sie ihre digitalen
Nachrichten wie gewohnt in ihr Postfach.
Ob hier irgendjemand irgendwas gewohnt ist, was digital ist.
Das leitet mich auch tatsächlich zu meiner Frage, Tim. gibt es eigentlich mehr,
also gibt es mehr digitale Dienstleistungen des Staates oder mehr digitale Anmeldemöglichkeiten.
Also Authentifizierungsmöglichkeiten.
Ist klar. Gibt es mehr Dienstleistungen oder Leute, die diese in die Hand sprungen? Das ist die dritte.
Das ist die dritte Dimension.
Ja, keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt. Ich frage mich auch, ob es jemanden gibt,
der da wirklich einen Überblick hat.
Insbesondere frage ich mich, ob der Starter einen Überblick hat.
Und wenn er den hat, wo ist der? Das wäre doch mal ganz nett.
Wirklich so eine komplette Tapete, so ein Org-Chart der IDs und Dienstleistungsoptionen.
Das könnte noch mal ganz lustig werden.
Weißt du, was eigentlich ganz cool wäre? Also kennst du, ich glaube das heißt Design Thinking.
Kennst du das?
Ja, das ist ein Studienwerk. Wenn da so Leute... Ist das ein Studi... Ja, tatsächlich.
Kannst du studieren.
Ich dachte, das wäre eher so eine... Aber okay, gut, kann man studieren.
Also kann ich mir auch vorstellen.
Jedenfalls ist das so, also was ich darunter verstehe, vielleicht verstehe ich
auch das falsche darunter, dass dann irgendwie so, dass die Leute sich Gedanken
machen über so User Journeys und Persona und sowas alles, das ist das,
oder? Oder ist das was anderes?
Das ist so ein Designprozess, irgendwie so ein sechsteiliger Sechs-Schritte-Prozess.
Verstehen, beobachten, Standpunkt definieren, Ideen finden. Prototyptisten.
Na und dann müssen die immer so, ich bin eine Rentnerin aus Leipzig und ich
möchte mein Moped-Kennzeichen verlängern für mein E-Roller.
Eine User-Story.
Das ist eine User-Story. So und jetzt stelle ich mir mal vor,
wenn man jetzt mal so einen Studiengang Design-Thinkerinnen nimmt und sagt,
bildet doch mal hier die 16 Bundesländer ihre Dienstleistungen,
die Authentifizierungsmöglichkeiten ab, ohne Fax.
Und dann müssen die einfach mal quasi diesen Raum abbilden, was so alles geht.
Also wie viele IDs brauche ich, um sämtliche Dienstleistungen meines Bundeslandes
in Anspruch nehmen zu können.
Und jetzt ist die Frage, ist es ein lösbarer Problemraum?
Also ist das noch erfassbar oder ist das gar nicht mehr erfassbar?
Ist die Bundesrepublik Deutschland touring complete?
Ja, die Frage wäre, ich stelle mir das so ein bisschen vor, so weißt du,
dass es dann am Ende sowas ist, wie du brauchst so eine KI wie AlphaGo,
die quasi die Ideallösung kann, aber nicht sagen kann, was die Lösung ist.
Ja, es gibt dann immer noch jemanden, der besser ist.
Ich glaube auf jeden Fall, der Problem ist relativ klein, weil es gibt ja gar
nicht so viele Dienstleistungen. Daran wird es liegen.
Demnächst kommt bestimmt auch das Chatfrontend mit KI, mit dem du dich über
Problemlose unterhalten kannst. Nach drei Stunden Diskussion schreit es nur noch lauter Hitler.
Wenn du mit einem Menschen redest.
Ach so, dann wollte ich noch, ein Feedback gab es noch, das Feedback kam in
Form eines Päckchens bei mir an.
Und zwar in der Sendung mit Khaleesi habe ich ja über diese Aufblas-Dinosaurier-Kostüme gesprochen.
Und in der Sendung noch einen auf meine Wunschliste geparkt.
Und ich glaube, so am Vormittag des nächsten Tages war der schon von der Wunschliste
runter und zwei Tage später war er hier. Und ich hab jetzt auch so ein Dinosaurier.
Und ich kann dir sagen, Tim, Dein Leben ist anders geworden.
Es ist einfach so, zum Beispiel, Das wirst du ganz neu kennen.
Abstand halten in der Supermarkt-Schlange. Kein Thema.
Das ist ein super Ding. Kann ich nur empfehlen. Dinosaurier-Kostüm.
Das muss sein. Da haben wir mich sehr darüber gefreut.
Wie über alles, übrigens, was man mir schenkt. was man mir schenkt.
Aber das kennt man ja, das ist jetzt keine Besonderheit. Tim,
wir haben eigentlich ein relativ blödes Jubiläum.
Wir haben Jubiläum?
Also die ganze Welt?
Ja, ja, der Ukraine-Krieg. Ich hab's schon angesprochen.
Ist jetzt genau ein Jahr, ne?
Ja, so sieht's aus. Ist sehr bedauernswert.
Möchtest du da was zu sagen?
Weiß nicht, was soll ich dazu sagen? Also ich meine, es ist ein globales Problem,
aber es ist auch irgendwie so ein mentales Problem für unsere Gesellschaft.
Wenn ich mir so anschaue, was so manche Leute so von sich geben in unserer Gesellschaft
zu diesem Thema, muss ich irgendwie sagen, was läuft eigentlich falsch bei euch?
Ich kann persönlich wenig nachvollziehen, dass man da nicht eine ganz klare
Haltung einnimmt und sagt, hier ist einfach 150 Prozent Solidarität angesagt.
Aber offensichtlich sind manche dann auch so in ihrem Wohlstandsleben so weit verwahrlos,
dass sie dann doch eher diese Option aus den Augen, aus dem Sinn wählen und
sich alle möglichen Gründe einfallen lassen, warum irgendwie eine Unterstützung
eines angegriffenen Staates unter diesen Bedingungen keine Option ist.
Das kann ich persönlich überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen.
Und ich hoffe, dass mal wieder nur Randfiguren bleiben werden und das im Kern
die Gesellschaft ganz klar Stellung bezieht.
Insbesondere und gerade ob der deutschen Vergangenheit, finde ich,
haben wir doppelt und dreifache Verpflichtung dazu.
Und damit meine ich nicht nur die Nazi-Vergangenheit, die man meistens immer
meint, wenn man von deutscher Vergangenheit spricht.
Ich denke, dass hier auch die Vergangenheit der letzten 20 Jahre,
wie sich Deutschland hier im Konfliktfall Ukraine, der ja schon länger als ein Jahr tobt.
Ich meine, der Krieg mit Russland ist nicht ein Jahr alt. Es ist nur der Überfall
auf das bisher noch nicht besetzte Gebiet, was ein Jahr alt ist.
Und das hat alles schon vor acht Jahren begonnen.
Und seitdem hat sich Deutschland eher rausgehalten und war sehr zufrieden damit,
schön billig Gas und Öl zu beziehen.
So nach dem Motto uns geht es gut und so soll es bleiben und alles andere sind Kollateralschäden.
Und das ist halt einfach eine sehr unverantwortungsvolle Position schon immer gewesen.
Gewesen und jetzt haben wir das böse Erwachen, dass wenn wir eben nicht klar
Stellung beziehen zu solchen Sachen und dann auch unser politisches Handeln
danach ausrichten, dass es dann irgendwann doppelt und dreifach uns auf den Kopf fällt.
So und jetzt haben wir halt den Salat und die wirtschaftlichen Konsequenzen davon.
Das ist genau der Punkt mit dem, was also was was die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
über Jahrzehnte für einen Führungsanspruch,
Freiheitsversprechen und was sich alles in Europa und über Europas Grenzen und
Grenzerweiterungen hinaus dargestellt hat.
Das wird jetzt halt mal auf die Probe gestellt und da finde ich schon sehr erstaunlich,
wie eben dann dann doch eine.
Sehr große regionale Macht wie Deutschland,
wo es dann viele Menschen gibt, die irgendwie den Anspruch erheben,
sie mögen das nicht, diese Machtanspruch,
mit dem eben nicht nur immer, ja ich bin geil, sondern ich muss jetzt auch mal
mich in der unangenehmen Situation halt auch mal meinen Führungsanspruch behaupten,
dass man sich dann da zurückziehen soll.
Und dass man nicht versteht, was das für eine bittere Konsequenz haben wird,
wenn dann erst mal VW, BMW,
Daimler-Pleite sind und wir irgendwie auf dem Weltmarkt mit unseren Verbrennungsmotoren
niemanden mehr beeindrucken und entsprechend hier dieses ganze Landberg abgeht mit unseren.
Ungebildeten digital-analphabetischen Studien abschließenden,
dass man in der Situation dann eigentlich vielleicht ganz gerne noch die drei
Karma-Punkte haben will, dass man damals sich gegen Russland gestellt hat.
Also allein aus dem Grund sollte das eigentlich relativ klar sein,
dass man jetzt mal für die vielen Versprechen und Freiheit und Frieden und was
man hier alles hochhält.
Leider auch einstehen muss. Wäre mir auch lieber, das nicht zu machen.
Habe ich auch nicht, weil jetzt gerade wieder Thema hier hast du mitbekommen.
Campino jetzt natürlich lange raus aus dem wehrfähigen Alter.
Wie alt ist Campino? 60 oder sowas?
Weiß nicht.
Ich würde den jetzt mal schätzen, der ist 20 Jahre älter als ich,
ist er auf jeden Fall. 60, gut geschätzt.
Mehr als 20 Jahre alt als ich, da lege ich jetzt Wert drauf.
Der hat jetzt gesagt, wenn man ihn jetzt nochmal vor die Wahl stellen würde,
dann würde er vielleicht den Wehrdienst nicht verweigern.
Das ist natürlich Wohlfall in dem Alter, so einen Spruch zu kloppen.
Ich würde meinen Wehrdienst nach wie vor verweigern, bin ich ganz ehrlich.
Aber das ist nur so eine Sache.
Über viele Dinge wird jetzt halt mal ein bisschen mehr nachgedacht und das kann
eigentlich auch gut tun.
Und da brauchst du natürlich auch solche Wagenknechte und sonstigen Leute,
die sich da unqualifiziert dazu äußern.
Es auch lieber keinen Krieg zu haben und ich bin auch nach wie vor überzeugter
Pazifist, Aber ich sehe gerade leider keine Anwendungsmöglichkeiten.
Meiner pazifistischen Ideen. Insbesondere nicht, wenn ich sie den Menschen nahebringen
möchte, die gerade einfach mal angegriffen werden.
Fall mir gerade keine überzeugenden Argumente ein.
Ja, ich mein, keinen Krieg zu wollen, ist ja ein nachvollziehbarer...
Ja, aber die Ukrainer doch auch nicht. Die haben doch auch nicht gesagt, dass sie das wollen.
Genau so, aber wenn dieser Krieg einem vor die Haustür getragen wird,
dann hat man halt keine andere Möglichkeit als sich zu wären,
wenn man sich nicht einfach abschlachten lassen möchte.
Und die eigentliche Frage, die im Raum steht, ist, dulden wir halt Genozid oder nicht?
Und das ist halt etwas, was wir, glaube ich, einfach zu verhindern haben.
Und da bin ich auch ehrlich gesagt recht froh, dass es Leute gibt,
die sich dem Militär dann auch stellen und da einen entsprechenden Schutzschirm
auch aufzustellen, in der Lage sind.
So, das ist eine persönliche Entscheidung, ob man sich sozusagen anschließt
oder nicht, aber ich kann mit beiden Entscheidungen leben.
Stell dir vor, es ist Krieg und Campino geht hin.
Aber weißt du, was auch noch eine kleine Rolle spielt?
Wir können ja nicht einfach ein Thema hier behandeln, ohne dass ich nochmal
sage, dass ich recht hatte.
Und zwar Cyberwar, großes Thema gewesen.
Das war, da war ich längere Wochen damit beschäftigt,
hier in der Sendung und in anderen Sendungen,
diese kleinen unbedeutenden TV-Sendungen, die es da noch so gibt und so,
neben uns, zu erklären, was denn so, was ein Cyberwar ist und warum es ihn nicht geben wird.
Ja und jetzt ist ein ja kann man sagen gab es
ein cyber war nicht so wirklich Es gab den
angriff auf das casad okay ja es
gab unmengen an dedos angriffen auf irgendwelche
webseiten die von denen niemand wusste bevor sie in Nachrichten waren weil es
darauf dedos angriffe gab ja da gab es ja diesen diesen dedos angriffe auf flughafen
webseiten wo dann die flughafen betreiber davon erfahren haben,
weil die Presse bei ihnen angefragt hat.
Also es war quasi sowas von egal, diese Webseite, dass das Unternehmen das noch
nicht mal gemerkt hat oder das Betreiberunternehmen noch nicht mal gemerkt hat,
dass die Website dauernd war.
Es gab dann die eine oder andere, gut mal in eine Fernsehübertragung eingegriffen,
wunderschön, dann gab es diese Geschichte, dass alle Taxis von Yandex irgendwie
in Moskau irgendwo hingerufen wurden,
aber das, wovon immer die Rede war, ja, oh mein Gott, die Infrastruktur,
die kritische Infrastruktur geht jetzt aus und wir werden alle frieren,
hat nicht stattgefunden.
Haben wir auch so vorhergesagt, dass es so nicht stattfinden wird,
haben wir auch erklärt, warum das so ist.
Weil diese Angriffe, Kasat, klar ein militärisch genutztes,
schrägstrich nutzbares Satellitenkommunikationssystem ist natürlich ein Angriffsziel,
insbesondere, wenn es eine Invasion gibt, ja, leuchtet ein.
Aber alles andere macht eben strategisch im dieser Kriegsführung wenig Sinn
und entsprechend wird da auch nicht rein investiert.
Und?
Ja, habe ich vor einem Jahr gesagt, stimmt immer noch.
Wenn ich das finde.
Alright.
Krass recht gehabt.
Na schön. Fake-News-Kampagnen gibt es aber und das ist wiederum also Thema hybride Kriegsführung.
Diese Woche, müsste diese Woche noch sein, der Spiegel-Titel mit einer israelischen
Gruppe, dem Team Horre, die...
Dass das Destabilisieren von Demokratien offenbar als Dienstleistungen verkaufen an alle,
die nichts gegen Israel, nichts gegen die USA und nichts gegen Putin unternehmen wollen,
mit anderen Worten in Ländern, wo nicht ganz so genau hingeschaut wird und wo
auf die Demokratie nicht ganz so viel Wert gelegt wird von anderen,
wie wir jetzt Wert auf die Demokratie der Ukraine legen.
Dieser Teil in der Auseinandersetzung zwischen Staaten scheint doch sehr viel
größer zu sein und zu werden, als man vielleicht gedacht hat.
Also die freie Öffentlichkeit als Faktor zur Destabilisierung von Demokratien
zu nutzen, ist ja eine Strategie, die wir wirklich überall die ganze Zeit sehen.
Und das ist auch mein Eindruck, so ein bisschen das, wogegen kein Kraut gewachsen ist.
Schön wäre es natürlich, wenn wir jetzt verantwortungsvolle soziale Netzwerke
hätten, die das Problem versuchen würden zu begrenzen.
Für eines der einflussreichsten sozialen Netzwerke ist leider gerade das Gegenteil der Fall.
Ja. Aber heute reden wir nicht über Twitter.
Jetzt noch nicht. Noch nicht. gleich zum,
So, Flughafen Frankfurt, ja, ich hab
grad schon gesagt, DEDOS Angriffe auf Flughafen-Websites, großes Thema.
In Wirklichkeit brauchst du einfach nur einen guten alten deutschen Bagger-Fahrer,
der war irgendwo baggert und ein Glasfaserkabel erreicht, was dann in Folge dessen kaputt ist.
Und die ganze Lufthansa musste am Boden bleiben. Ja. Wenn ich die,
oder so gut wie die ganze Lufthansa.
Ja, also teilweise haben die Kroos durch viel manuelle Arbeit, also was ist passiert?
Es gab Bauarbeiten an einer Bahnstrecke, ja.
Da fand ich den Hinweis, dass die Bahn jetzt doch aktiv daran arbeitet,
den Verkehr auf die Bahn zu bringen.
Ganz interessant. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass das das Problem ist.
Das Problem war primär, dass hier offensichtlich nicht ausreichend Informationen
darüber lagen, wo Kabel lagen und wie man dann entsprechend mit diesen Kabellagen umgehen kann.
Oder sollte ich Kabelagen sagen? Witz. Quillt aus allen Ritzen.
Auf jeden Fall wurden diese Glasfasern durchtrennt und das führte natürlich
dazu, dass bestimmte Verbindungen nicht mehr funktionierten.
Und das waren Verbindungen, die weil das ganze sich in Frankfurt ereignet hat,
sehr viel mit dem Flughafen zu tun haben.
Das führte dann aber offensichtlich nur bei der Lufthansa und ihren Verbündeten,
also dem ganzen, wie heißt dieses Netzwerk, wo auch so Austrian und so weiter
drin ist, also was halt alles noch so zu Lufthansa dazugehört.
Star Alliance.
Star, ich weiß nicht, war es die ganze Alliance? Ich glaube,
es betraf jetzt nur Lufthansa und alle Töchter, also Austrian Airlines und was
was da alles noch mit dazu gehört, die waren unmittelbar davon betroffen und
und zwar konkret das Check-in System.
Das heißt, was nicht mehr funktionierte, war die Online-Einbuchungsgeschichte.
Wo das anfing, aufhört, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber das war sozusagen das Ding.
Und überall da, wo die Crews es geschafft haben, den Check-in dann manuell vorzunehmen,
was dann eben sehr viel länger gedauert hat, flogen dann auch noch einzelne
Flieger. Aber es war halt eben diese übliche Kaskade.
Es führte dann vor allem zu großen Ausfällen in Frankfurt.
Was dann wiederum das Problem hat, dass dann diese ganzen nicht wegfliegenden
Lufthansa Flugzeuge den Platz beanspruchten,
den andere Flugzeuge gebraucht hätten, wenn sie dort landen,
sodass die dann eben auch umgeleitet werden mussten.
Und das führte dann für mindestens einen Tag zu großer Panik.
Und alle fragten sich natürlich jetzt, okay, was jetzt hier eigentlich passiert?
Und natürlich immer auch die Frage, wer ist jetzt schuld?
Und das ist eine ganz interessante Frage, weil solche Infrastruktur-Vorfälle,
Na ja gut, da gibt es halt verschiedenste Schuldfragen, die man klären kann.
Also erstmal, wie konnte das überhaupt passieren? Kann man sagen,
okay, Shit happens, muss man immer von ausgehen.
Aber selbstverständlich ist es natürlich, bei solchen Bauarbeiten muss natürlich
in irgendeiner Form dafür Sicherheit getragen werden, dass kritische Infrastruktur
nicht zerstört wird. Das geht natürlich nicht nur für Glasfaserleitungen,
das geht genauso für Stromleitungen, Gasleitungen, etc.
Gutes Verzeichnis und eine gute Kommunikation von was liegt wo und wo darf ich
mit dem Bagger reinfahren und wo nicht. So was muss halt sichergestellt werden.
Also da ist definitiv schon mal irgendein Fehler passiert.
Wo auch immer der dann konkret gelegen hat.
Betroffen waren dann halt Leitungen
der Telekom und die Auswirkungen waren dann eben bei der Lufthansa.
Und dann ist natürlich die Frage, okay gut, also wer hat jetzt hier für den
Notfall nicht gut vorbereitet.
Und da muss man natürlich sagen,
okay, offensichtlich gab es irgendwelche Probleme mit der Lufthansa.
Nur weil jetzt ein Kabel fehlt, darf natürlich nicht so ein System komplett ausfallen.
Also die Redundanz muss natürlich hier in irgendeiner Form sichergestellt werden.
Soweit ich das gehört habe, war es jetzt nicht so, dass sie das nicht auch schon
vorher mal berücksichtigt haben.
Trotzdem führte es dann wohl in der Folge zu bottlenecks
die dann das system überfordert haben ich
habe ich weiß dass ich es irgendwie im fernsehen gesehen habe deswegen war es
wahrscheinlich wie ztf heute oder tagesschau oder sowas wo jemand so die art
kabel die die da durch geht durch gebaggert haben, mal gezeigt hat.
Das war jetzt nicht so eine gelbe Faser, wie wir sie haben.
Das war so ein richtig dicker Strand.
Ja, ich glaube, der meinte eben so 500 oder 5.000 Einzelfasern.
Also irgendwie so eine Menge, wo ich sagte, wer dies bleißen muss.
Da bist du halt richtig, richtig, das ist richtig ich weiß gar nicht,
wie man so ein Kabel repariert. Ich muss also bei irgendwie einer Faser oder
fünf wissen noch wie es geht.
Bei so vielen weiß ich es tatsächlich nicht. Da wird sicherlich,
also am Ende wird es gespleißt worden sein oder irgendwas, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall ein ganz schön beschissener Tag und ja der Ausfall,
ein solcher Ausfall darf nicht sein, sein, dieses Buchungssystem.
Wer ungefähr versteht, dass Leute Flüge buchen und einchecken müssen,
sollte erkennen, dass das eben ein missionskritisches System ist und dass das
redundant liegen muss oder redundant angebunden sein muss.
Das sollte schon klar sein. Also Das darf.
Erstens hätte niemand in der Ecke baggern dürfen.
Und dass das aber passiert, damit hätte man rechnen sollen, weil das passiert
andauernd, dass ein Bagger eine Faser erreicht.
Ich habe vor Jahren mal so einen schönen Vortrag im CCC Berlin,
da hat der Kai, den Du kennst ja auch.
So ein bisschen davon erzählt, der ist ja beruflich so in, wir bauen das Internet, ne?
Und der sagte dann auch so was so bei Colt oder in Frankfurt,
wenn da in bestimmten Straßen, wenn da nur der Bagger kommt,
ja dann rennen die alle schreit runter, weil sie wissen, dass da ihr X angeschlossen,
ihr Kicks angeschlossen ist und versuchen den Baggerfahrer, ich bin so,
nein, nein, nein, wer sind Sie, wir rufen die Bullen.
Also das ist schon, ja, aber gerade weil das die ganze Zeit trotzdem passiert,
muss man bei kritischen Infrastrukturen eben solche Dinge planen.
Bei der Deutschen Bahn, die ja jetzt auch erst kürzlich gelernt hat,
was das mit den Fasern auf sich hat, es ist ja nicht so lange her,
dass da eben auch zwei missionskritische Faserstränge kaputtgegangen sind.
Die mussten aber wenigstens 600 Kilometer voneinander entfernt liegen.
Da sieht man, dass die Deutsche Bahn es den Baggerfahrern ein bisschen schwerer gemacht hat.
Ich habe jetzt keine tiefe Kenntnis darüber, sondern ich versuche so ein bisschen
meinen Eindruck zu schildern, von dem was ich so gelesen habe,
weil ich nicht wirklich genau weiß was passiert ist.
Aber es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass es schon...
Alternative Rauten gegeben hat, ich vermute mal es gab eine Art sich aufstauend,
so ein Aufstauproblem, was dann erst so in zweiter und dritter Ordnung zu den
eigentlichen Problemen geführt hat.
Also sie waren wohl schon auf, diese Leitung ist gekappt, vorbereitet,
nur hat es dann aus irgendwelchen anderen Gründen Flaschenhälse erzeugt,
etc. Wie gesagt, genau weiß ich es nicht.
Nur, und es ist sowas natürlich auch immer nur begrenzt testbar.
Also man kann sowas testen, aber das hat seine Grenzen, klar.
Also ich muss auch echt sagen, als ich diesen Kabelstrang, den das Männchen
da in die Kamera gehalten habe, gesehen habe, da habe ich gesagt,
bevor ich das Ding gespleißt habe, legt er lieber einfach neu.
Du reißt lieber die Straße auf und legst ein neues Kabel rein.
Insofern muss ich auch noch mal sagen, es war nur ein Tag.
Sie haben es bei aller Kritik, die man jetzt anbringen kann,
weil man tacht, und das ist ja auch ein riesiger Schaden, jetzt wird man sich
irgendwie, werden sie sicherlich noch jahrelang sich darüber beklagen,
wer gegenseitig verklagen, wer jetzt den Schaden regulieren muss oder so.
Ob jetzt die Privathaftpflicht von dem Baggerfahrer reicht Oder vielleicht nicht.
Aber insgesamt trotz eines solchen krassen Ausfalls schien der ja in kürzester
Zeit dann doch wieder in die Gänge zu kommen. Also das ist...
Ja, kann man schon so sehen. Wobei ich auch sagen muss, die Kosten,
die das jetzt verursacht hat, das wird teuer gewesen sein.
Was kostet denn so ein Meter Glasfaser?
Glas.
Ich guck mal, da gab es gerade was bei Aldi.
Na ja, also du kannst ja vorstellen, Hunderte von Flügen mit Erstattung,
bla bla bla, Zugticket, Hotels und was nicht alles. Das zieht ja einen riesigen
Ratten-Schwanz nach sich. Es geht einfach in die Millionen.
Also für das Geld hätte man eine ganze Menge Tests und Audits und Notfallprüfungen durchführen können.
Und man hätte den Image-Schaden noch nicht dazu gehabt.
Also das ist dann schon etwas, was sicherlich nicht komplett vermeidbar ist.
Also die Vorstellung, dass man alles immer testen kann und solche Fälle zu 100
Prozent abdeckt bekommt, ist natürlich eine Illusion, weil die Welt ist zu komplex
und Fehlersituationen sind zu komplex.
Ich weiß ja nicht genau, was ist da passiert. Ist dann irgendwie ein Server
nochmal zusätzlich abgeraucht,
weil er mit der Last nicht klar kam, ist ein anderer Provider in die Knie gegangen,
weil dann irgendwie die ganzen Daten, die nicht über die Telekom gingen,
woanders sozusagen die alternative Verbindung dann auch noch tot gemacht hat.
Also irgendwo hat dann auch Redundanz so ein bisschen ihr Ende.
Und natürlich werden solche Systeme jetzt auch nicht auf die gleiche Art und
Weise getestet wie Flüge zum Mars oder so.
Obwohl manchmal würde man sich's wünschen.
So dann Thomas Lohninger hat einen Erfolg zu feiern. Stream-off.
Stream-on hat er, also das war ja...
Wie lange ist es her, dass wir das hier diskutiert haben?
Wir haben es ja über Jahre diskutiert.
Ja, aber das fing auch vor langer, langer Zeit an.
Seit es das gibt, hat er ja gesagt, dass es illegal ist, das so zu machen.
Und das hatte er recht. Ich habe das ja schon, weiß nicht, seit drei Jahren
diskutiere ich das mit Wolfgang Kopf, wenn ich ihn sehe.
Das ist der, einer der, ich glaube, das ist der Cheflobby der Deutschen Telekom
oder der, ja, wahrscheinlich also der Leiter Government Affairs oder sowas, Regulatory Affairs.
Er sagt, hier wisst ihr doch, dass man das nicht darf. Das ist doch,
ist ja auch überhaupt völlig klar. Und dann hat es eben die Bundesnetzagentur
untersagt ihn schon vor längerer Zeit, das zu bewerben.
Aber jetzt endet das ja quasi das Bestandskundengeschäft.
Ja, also auch ich, ich hab einen deutschen Telekom Vertrag, ich hab natürlich
auch Stream On. Ich bin ja nicht verrückt, wenn ich Kunde, natürlich nehme ich das.
Und jetzt hab ich hier folgende Mail bekommen, mal guten Tag.
Schreiben die mir eine Mail, fängt einen guten Tag an. Wenn ich eine E-Mail
bekomme, beginnt die mit Guten Morgen Linus, nicht guten Tag.
Aufgrund eines Urteils des Europäischen Gerichtshofs können wir die Zubuchoptionen
des Stream-Ordens zum Mobilfunkverträgen zum 31.3.
Wir bedauern dies sehr. Was ist der Hintergrund, die Bundesnetzagentur untersagt,
Optionen anzubieten, bei denen der Datenverbrauch durch Partnerdienste nicht
auf das im Tarif inkludierte Volumen angerechnet wird?
Dies gilt sowohl für die Telekom als auch für andere Mobilfunkanbieter.
Stream on Music, Stream on Music und Video, Stream on Gaming,
Stream on Social und Chat, Stream on Music Business, Stream on Music Video Business,
Stream on Gaming Business und Stream on Social and Chat Business.
So, die werden jetzt alle gekündigt.
Stream on Gaming Business, stelle ich mir auch ein interessantes Business-Modell vor.
Aber so, allein an den Bereichen, die Sie mit diesem Streamer abgedeckt haben,
Musik hattest alle Musikstreamer, Video hattest du alle Videostreamer,
Gaming, weiß ich nicht, kenne ich nicht, Social in Chat, da viel auch Twitter drunter.
Und es war tatsächlich so, dass ich damit für einen größeren Teil meiner bandbreitenintensiven
Nutzung de facto eine Flatrate hatte.
Das, was ich bei der Deutschen Telekom noch an Gigabytes bezahle,
die nutze ich für VPN-Verbindungen nach Hause und Sonstiges.
Das ist der Grund, dass ich einen großen teuren Vertrag habe für verschlüsselten
Traffic oder groß breitbeinigen trafficierten Podcasten und solche Dinge,
die nicht unter das Inklusivvolumen fallen.
VPN-Verbindung, so nennt man das also heutzutage.
Wie verbindest du dich denn nach Hause?
Nee, ist schon okay. VPN-Verbindung ist ein schönes Kurzwort.
Tunnelblick heißt es, ich benutze tatsächlich VPN. OpenVPN, um genau zu sein.
Mit WireGuard bin ich nie klargekommen.
Okay, also hier. Und jetzt schalten Sie das ab.
Aber es gibt eine gute Nachricht. Sie degradieren im Prinzip meinen Freivolumentarif
plus, was hatte ich irgendwie 40 Gig oder sowas.
Es ist eine massive Einschränkung des Datenvolumens, das ich noch nutzen kann.
Aber es gibt eine gute Nachricht.
Und?
Sie schenken mir 90 Tage deutschlandweit unbegrenztes Datenvolumen zum sorgenfreien Surfen.
Sorgenfreies Surfen, davon habe ich das mal geträumt.
90 Tage sorgenfrei. Warte, ich habe einen 24-Modern-Vertrag, ne?
Sorgst du dich eigentlich auch beim Surfen immer so sehr?
Ich bin besorgter Surfer. Das ist eine Frechheit. Also ich meine,
hier muss man auch sagen, dass wahrscheinlich das Urteil dann hier auch nicht
ausreichend scharf war, weil nicht nur hätte man es ihnen versagen müssen, was ja geschehen ist.
Sie hätten Strafe bezahlen müssen.
Nein, sie hätten einfach sicherstellen müssen, dass die Leute,
denen sie diesen Vertrag gegeben
haben, auch danach zu dem versprochenen Bedingung weiter surfen können.
Richtig.
Weil jetzt kostet es nämlich auf jeden Fall das, was sie versprochen haben und
weswegen die Leute an diese Verträge eingegangen sind.
Das kostet jetzt auf einmal. Und dann zeigen die halt auch vor die Behörden
und sagen, ja die sind schuld dir, wir wollten euch das ja geben.
Exakt.
Und es hätte halt einfach sein müssen so, ja okay sorry, jetzt habt ihr hier
nicht 90 Tage sorgenfrei, sondern einfach mal sorgenfrei mit diesem Vertrag.
Wir wissen, du hast das Ding wegen Stream On genommen, jetzt kriegst du unbegrenztes
Datenvolumen. Und das ist ja das Skurrile an diesen Tarifen.
Ich habe da ja streckenweise mit Sicherheit sehr viele Gigabytes durchgeballert.
Und sie waren ja in der Lage, mir diese Anzahl Gigabytes zu liefern zu den Konditionen.
Die haben ja trotzdem noch mit mir Geld verdient. Es ist ja nicht so,
als hätten sie jetzt kein Geld mit meinem Mobilfunkvertrag verdient,
weil ich, sagen wir mal, vielleicht 100 Gig dadurch geblasen habe statt 40.
Und sie sind ja sogar offenbar in der Lage, allen Betroffenen 90 Tage sorgenfreies Surfen zu ermöglichen.
Und danach kommt die Sorge?
Danach kommt die Sorge. Das heißt, was Thomas Lohninger schon immer gesagt hat,
ihr könnt offensichtlich doch dieses Datenvolumen bereitstellen,
dann gibt es den Leuten doch auch einfach.
Der Hintergrund, dass sie diese Bandbreiten-Demitierungen haben,
es gibt einen einzigen Grund dafür und das ist die Preisdifferenzierung im Prinzip,
den Leuten irgendwie unterschiedliche Preise zu bieten und das irgendwie virtuell
an eine Nutzung zu binden.
Was im Zweifelsfall natürlich einfach nur heißt, kauf mehr. Der gleiche Grund,
warum Apple dir irgendwie ein MacBook Pro, weiß nicht, für 1000 Euro anbietet
mit 8 GB RAM und 256 GB SSD oder so.
Das gleiche, als würde dir ein Ferrari mit 5 Liter Tank anbieten.
Weil die wissen, dass du wahrscheinlich den Ferrari mindestens mit 20 Liter
Tank, wenn nicht mit 80 Liter Tank kaufst. Der kostet aber dann mehr.
Also es ist alles da, es funktioniert auch alles, aber es gibt diese kleine
Verarschung damit dran.
Wunderschön ist aber auch wie das überhaupt nicht.
Kritisch hinterfragt wird. Wenn ich überhaupt nirgendwo, ich hab das sogar hier
auf Mastodon, dann hab ich gesagt, hier, dann lasst damit euch machen,
wo bleibt der Aufschrei?
Und dann gibt's Antworten, ja die haben ja mein Inklusivvolumen um 5 Gig erhöht oder sowas. 5 Gig?
Ich rede doch nicht von 5 Gig. Wenn ich von sorgenfreiem Surfen rede,
rede ich doch nicht von 5 Gig oder 10.
Oder voll geil, wenn ich acht Karten habe, wird es pro Karte billiger.
Ja geil, dafür hast du acht Karten.
Also das sind keine überzeugenden Argumente, aber viel schöner finde ich,
was du dann irgendwie auf golem.de zum Beispiel liest.
Die deutsche Telekom verteilt in einer Sonderaktion unbegrenztes Datenvolumen
in etlichen Mobilfunk-Tarifen an ihre Kunden.
Lalalalala, gibt es aber nicht automatisch. Mit der Aktion, wie die Telekom
feiern, dass sie kürzlich für das gut ausgebaute Mobilfunknetz ausgezeichnet
wurde, berechtigte Kunden müssen das Datengeschenk aktiv buchen.
Das ist auch so geil, weil sie natürlich wissen, dass der größere Teil der Leute
vergisst, das Datengeschenk zu buchen.
Und da muss irgendwie die Mein-Magenta-App oder irgendein Scheiß.
Und irgendwo unten steht, wer einen Smartphone-Tarif der Deutsche Telekom mit
Stream-on-Funktion besitzt, kann die Stream-on-Funktion ab dem 1.
April nicht mehr nutzen.
Die kriegen einmaliges Datengeschenk. Okay, sind jetzt getrennt.
Ach so, sorry. Also das eine ist März und da kriegst du nochmal irgendwie eine
Augenwischerei und dass du zwei Daten-Geschenke kriegst.
Und viele Telekom-Tarife sind zur Einlösung berechtigt.
So sieht das aus. Also, die haben es wirklich geschafft,
da muss man an die Deutsche Telekom gratulieren, die haben es geschafft,
jetzt irgendwie den Schwarzen Peter zur Bundesnetzagentur zu schieben und dass
nicht der größere Teil ihrer Kunden sagt,
Moment mal, wenn ich doch bisher hier 100 Gig durchblasen konnte für sagen wir
mal, was kostet man 40 Euro?
Warum wird mir das jetzt weggenommen zum gleichen Preis und ich soll mich hier
mit einem Datengeschenk zufriedengeben?
Weil natürlich viele Leute das auch nicht so extensiv genutzt haben vielleicht,
wie du. Das kommt ja auch noch dazu.
Na wieso?
Die Leute haben doch alle ihr Spotify und ihr Netflix. Netflix weiß ich jetzt
nicht, ob wirklich jemand über seinen Mobilfunktarif Netflix guckt.
Aber gerade die preisbewusste Surferin, die hat doch ein Spotify und ein Handy
mit wenig Speicher, weil man das alles streamen kann und das kostet jetzt alles wieder geld.
Ich habe gerade mal geguckt hier die erste Erwähnung die ich jetzt im Archiv
finden konnte von Stream On. 13. April 2017.
Ja da haben wir wahrscheinlich gesagt hier das ist nicht in Ordnung.
Übrigens haken wir jetzt auf der deutschen Telekom rum. Einziger Grund,
dass ich eben jetzt diesen Telekom Vertrag habe bei der bei Vodafone wird es ähnlich sein.
Bei Vodafone heißt es nicht Stream On, sondern PaaS. Die haben das Vodafone
PaaS für haste nicht gesehen genannt.
Und mehr oder weniger das gleiche in grün. Es betrifft ja alle Mobilfunkprovider,
weil die alle irgendwie solche netzneutralitätsverletzenden zu ihren Verträgen hatten.
Na gut, jetzt ist off.
So, nächstes Thema.
Ja, Potsdam. Haben wir gar nicht erzählt, Potsdam wurde ja irgendwie die Verwaltung
geowned vor einem Jahr oder so und jetzt wieder.
Weil es so schön war.
So und jetzt meldet sich Potsdam's Oberbürgermeister Mike Schubert und Mike
Schubert, ich muss es sagen, wird nicht mit AI geschrieben.
Obwohl er der Oberbürgermeister von Potsdam ist. Mike mit I.
Und der hat jetzt festgestellt, also Potsdames Verwaltung wird plattgemacht,
wiederhergestellt, wieder plattgemacht und jetzt sagt er,
ja, jetzt müssten sie Millionen ausgeben und die Kommunen können diesen wichtigen
Bestandteil der Daseinsvorsorge auf Dauer nicht allein für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger gewährleisten können.
Und deswegen sollen Land und Bund für Kommunen mehr Geld bereitstellen für Cyber-Sicherheit.
Und ich finde das faszinierend.
Denn es wird ja, es erscheint hier wieder so dieser, also es ist hier so dieser,
wir Ich könnte IT bauen, aber die sicher zu machen, kostet irgendwie extra.
Und ich freu mich an, welche Leute, die geraten sind, dass das jetzt extra kostet.
Vor allem dauerhaft extra.
Also wahrscheinlich haben die jetzt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht,
ob die irgendein Produkt haben, was sie jetzt da brauchen, irgendein IDA oder
sowas, was dann monatlich oder jährlich kostet.
Aber dieses wir brauchen jetzt dauerhaft zusätzliches Geld für IT-Sicherheit, das ist der Fehler.
Also weil die so denken, wurden die ein zweites Mal gehackt.
Weil was du ja eigentlich brauchst ist, und ich kann es gar nicht erzählen,
weil ich das jeden Tag erzähle, was du brauchst ist ein risikobasiertes,
vernünftiges Management deiner IT.
Und diese IT wird ja gemanagt, die wird ja von irgendwelchen Leuten betrieben,
die sich dann keine Gedanken darüber machen,
eine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung zu haben, die sich dann keine Gedanken darüber
machen, ein T-Ring-Modell ins Active Directory zu machen, die sich keine Gedanken
darüber machen, das Backup nicht ins Active Directory zu hängen.
Alles Dinge, die ja nicht, das ist ein einmaliger Aufwand, ganz ohne Frage, aber kein dauerhafter.
Und das macht mich tatsächlich auch beruflich wahnsinnig, Dass dieses verantwortungslose
Betreiben einer IT so zum Normalzustand erklärt wird und um die jetzt verantwortungsbewusst
oder halt mal vernünftig zu betreiben,
dass das irgendwie extra kosten soll.
Das ist jetzt, 3 Millionen Euro kostet jetzt Potsdam, bessere IT-Sicherheit pro Jahr.
Das kann nicht sein. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es einmalig 6 Millionen kostet
von mir aus, aber nicht pro Jahr drei.
Was ist das denn für eine Sicherheit, die keine dauerhafte Verbesserung herbeiführt?
Tja, das ist so überumwegende Erhöhung von Etats.
Ich kenne doch die ganze Bande. Ich weiß doch, wer da jetzt gerade bei denen
sitzt und denen irgendwie Einzelplatzlizenzen mit irgendeinem EDA aufschwätzt oder so.
Was nämlich das Problem überhaupt nicht löst.
Die ganze IT ist immer noch scheiße gemanagt und immer noch offensichtlich für
jemanden übernehmbar ohne den Einsatz von Chart-Software.
Das heißt, an der Resilienz dieser Infrastruktur hat sich überhaupt nichts geändert.
Aber wir zahlen jetzt 3 Millionen Euro im Jahr an irgendjemanden,
der auf seiner Website stehen hat wie am Cyber.
Weißt du, wenn jemand sagen würde, wir zahlen jetzt, wir zahlen drei Millionen
jährlich für besseren Brandschutz, dann würdest du sagen, das kann irgendwie nicht sein.
Man kann doch ein Haus bauen, was einfach nicht sofort niederbrennt.
Vielleicht wäre das sinnvoller.
Also zumindest, also stell dir mal vor, du müsstest für Brandschutz an deinem
Haus jährlich zahlen, statt einmal.
Das würdest du doch nicht akzeptieren.
Die Feuerlöscher, die laufen doch ab.
Ja, genauso wie die Windows Server von Berlin.
Ja, irgendwann nach zehn Jahren.
Das Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum ist überschritten. Okay, also es ist sicherlich
noch ein sehr weiter Weg. Und in einer Sache hat er natürlich Recht,
dass wir jetzt so weitergehen.
Werden eine nach der anderen Infrastruktur wird übernommen.
Es ist ja auch in den Unternehmen, geht es auch die ganze Zeit weiter.
Du kannst es ja jede Woche in der Zeitung lesen, welches Unternehmen wieder
betroffen wurde. Und das sind nur die, die groß genug sind, in die Zeitung zu kommen.
Du kannst dir, wenn du jetzt mal dir die Leaking-Seiten der Ransomware-Gangs anschaust,
die ja inzwischen nicht nur die Infrastruktur platt machen, sondern auch vorher
Daten exfiltrieren und die dann veröffentlichen, da kannst du ja dann schauen,
bei wem die so alles waren.
Ja, und das geht in allem fort. Und alle sagen danach, wir brauchen aber jetzt
irgendwie mehr Geld für Cyber, statt aus den Fehlern der anderen zu lernen und
resiliente Infrastrukturen zu bauen.
Und bin ich ein bisschen vorsichtig. Es ist ja einigen bekannt,
dass ich in diesem Bereich beruflich tätig bin.
Und es passiert mir leider häufig, dass es dann Unternehmen gibt,
die einen solchen Vorfall haben, die dann auch schwere...
Wie hieß das nochmal? Wir haben da mal so eine Sendungstitel gehabt.
Sonder auf Kosten durch besondere Schadenfälle? Oder wie hieß das nochmal?
Weil wir überlegt haben, wie man das in SKR 03 oder 04 buchen muss.
Was gerade nicht? Hast du noch ein bisschen mehr Assoziationsstil?
Ich glaube es war besondere Schadenfälle oder sowas bei der Sendungstelle.
Verluste durch außergewöhnliche Schadensverluste.
Ah ja. Die buchen dann ihren Verlust durch einen außergewöhnlichen Schadensfall
und kannst der Sonder abschreiben. Du hattest mir das damals alles echt.
Ja, das ist ein spezielles Bohrungskonto.
So, Verluste durch… Ach so vielleicht wollen die einfach da jetzt jährlich 3
Millionen für nächstes Mal was.
SKR 047552 Verluste durch außergewöhnliche Schadensfälle. Ja genau das war's.
So die buchen das dann und wenn du dann sagst, oh Leute wie wärs denn,
wenn wir uns jetzt mal damit auseinandersetzen, was wir falsch gemacht haben
in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren, ist den Angreifern jetzt, wenn die wiederkommen, zu erschweren.
Machen wir mal. Jetzt haben wir ja gesehen, welche Schäden hier entstehen können.
Lass uns doch mal was machen, dass wir dauerhaft diese Sorge los sind.
Also, wir hatten doch jetzt gerade erst den Schaden.
Ja genau, das wollen wir den noch mal? Nö. Ja, aber kommt halt noch mal.
Ja, wenn wir das jetzt nicht...
Ich dachte, wir sind jetzt immun.
Wie? Ich bin doch gerade erst über eine rote Ampel gegangen und vom LKW überfahren
worden. Das wird doch jetzt beim nächsten Mal nicht nochmal passieren. Ja doch!
Ich dachte immer, wenn man sich so ein Computervirus einfängt,
dann ist man danach immun.
Genau. Gibt es da nicht was von Ratiofarben?
Das wäre vielleicht ein Bio-Technisch. Da müsste man mal anrufen.
Ja, aber diese Denkweise ist dann sehr verbreitet und da ist natürlich auch
eine Botschaft, ich sage ja immer, die gleiche Gang wird dich nicht nochmal hacken.
Weil, den Rest des Internets, es gibt genug Leute, die es ihnen leicht machen
und sie würden ihren Ruf verspielen, wenn sie dich zweimal hacken.
Zumindest nachdem du gezahlt hast. In Potsdam ist mir jetzt nicht ganz klar,
ob das quasi die gleiche Gang nochmal war, weil sie nicht bezahlt haben oder
einfach die nächste, weil der Laden nicht ordentlich stand.
Dann ist es halt auch unerheblich, wenn du vom ersten Mal nicht gelernt hast
und das zweite Mal nochmal in so eine Situation rasselst, dann wäre es gut,
nicht danach zu sagen, Jetzt muss der Staat helfen.
Jetzt weiß ich auch nicht mehr weiter. Jetzt brauche ich aber drei Millionen vom Bund. Das ist...
Okay, nächstes Thema. Lass was. Ich...
Du regst dich nur auf.
Ja, ich rege mich wirklich ein bisschen darüber auf. Vor allem,
weil es immer so getan wird, als wären das irgendwelche Geheimnisse, die man wissen müsste.
Als wäre das so eine schwarze Magie, etwas zu bauen, Wo halt eine halbwegs vernünftige
rechte Trennung drin ist, dass einem nicht sofort jeder da durch rasiert.
Natürlich ist es auch dann, die Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht null,
aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass die Angreifer weiterziehen und woanders sich
Mühe geben, eben größer.
Ich leide mit dir. Wir haben es jetzt zumindest gesagt.
Wenn es nächstes Mal passiert ist, dann können wir sagen, wir haben es ja gleich gesagt.
Nächstes Mal wickeln wir Potsdam ab. Also ein drittes Mal machen wir das natürlich mit.
Und da ist doch dieser Design... In Potsdam ist doch das HPI-Institut,
da kannst du Design Thinking studieren.
Vielleicht sollst du mal versuchen, da nochmal drüber nachzudenken.
Und für das Schloss, da kauft doch bestimmt einer.
Die haben doch da so ein Schloss stehen, ne? Sainte-Souci oder Sainte-Souci, ja, ohne Sorgen.
Aber so ganz ohne Sorgen, um sie nicht zu sein. Da sollten sie mal bei der Zähne
Kopf rangen. Besorg ein freies Internet.
Die Kerze sieht aus. Saucy hosting. Der neue Saucy-Tarif.
Für besorgte Surfer.
So, jetzt hat Microsoft...
Es gibt ja Bing. Es gibt es immer noch. Microsoft hat ja jetzt,
also jetzt, Khaleesi hat das, du hast ja auch in der letzten Sendung schon darüber
gesprochen, jetzt auf jeden Fall noch im Ohr darüber gesprochen, dass jetzt ja google.
Versteht jetzt, dass sie ein unmittelbar, also es ist ja tatsächlich so mit
ChatGPT war das User Interface von Google, sah auf einmal, hatte das sofort
so ein Windows 95 Charme.
Davor war das einfach der Anfang vom Internet und dann kam,
so fing jede Internetreise an, egal wo sie hinführte, da ging man erstmal los
und fühlte sich modern, weil man googelte etwas und dann kam ChatGPT und da
war unmittelbar Google irgendwie so, hey, ist das denn ey?
Irgendwie so diese 32-Bit-Optik und so, das ist ja alles, das will man ja nicht.
Und dann ist Microsoft hingegangen, die ja relativ viel Geld in OpenAI hatten,
haben gesagt, ja voll geil, wir bauen jetzt ChatGPT bei uns in Bing ein.
In die Google, in ihr Google, ja?
Also bei Bing kann man ja googeln. So und… Und was das Ding da für Antworten
geliefert hat, wunderschön.
Zum Beispiel habe ich hier so einen wunderschönen Screenshot geschickt bekommen
von einem unserer treuen Hörer und Freunde von mir.
Wie viele Menschen leben auf dem Mars? Antwort 10 Milliarden.
Weil Mars ist ja der viertgrößte Planet von der Sonne entfernt und der zweitgrößte wie auch immer.
Mars ist der vierte Planet von der Sonne entfernt und der zweitkleinste in unserem Sonnensystem.
Und deswegen hat er eine Population von 10 Milliarden Menschen und die Regierung
stellt die masianische kongressionale Republik.
So, dann nächste Frage. Ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nicht,
ob das stimmt. Ja, aber der...
Also wahrscheinlich stimmt es nicht. Wahrscheinlich sind es weniger, die da wurden.
Und was ich auch sehr schön fand, dann hat ein Journalist von der New York Times
da mal mit dem Ding gechattet und ist dann zu dem,
also dieses Chatbing, ne,
Sydney heißt der, ne, haben sie das genannt, hat dann so nach mehreren,
also je länger du mit dem Ding gesprochen Hass wurde das eben sehr komisch.
Und sagte dann, du bist verheiratet, aber du liebst ja gar nicht deine Ehepartnerin.
Du bist verheiratet, aber du liebst mich. Und wenn man dann aber dem widersprochen hat,
gesagt hat, nee, ich bin glücklich verheiratet, dann hat Sidney gesagt,
nein, du bist nicht glücklich verheiratet, ihr liebt einander nicht,
du hattest nur ein langweiliges Valentinstag-Dinner und wurde also sehr, sehr komisch.
Und wenn man dann noch härter wurde, dann wurde Sydney auch emotional.
Und das Schöne, finde ich hier das Ende von dem Artikel, diese AI-Modelle halluzinieren
und denken sich Emotionen, wo es nicht wirklich welche gibt.
Aber das tun Menschen auch. Und nach ein paar Stunden, an Dienstagabend,
spürte ich eine sehr komische neue Emotion.
Das vorwarnende Gefühl, dass AI eine Schwelle überschritten hatte und dass die
Welt nie wieder die gleiche sein würde.
Habe ich jetzt mal kurz spontan übersetzt.
Und der Titel ist eine Unterhaltung mit Bing's Chatbox hinterließ mich zutiefst beunruhigt.
Reaktion von Microsoft.
Ja, Sie hätten jetzt festgestellt, dass also mit zunehmender Dauer der Konversation
das Ding einige Menschen beunruhigt.
Und deswegen begrenzen sie jetzt quasi die Chat-Tiefe auf fünf Interaktionen.
Also du kannst nicht mehr 50, du kannst nicht mehr den ganzen Tag mit dem Ding
chatten, bis es versucht dir irgendwie eine Scheidung nahe zu legen oder so,
sondern du kannst nur noch so fünf, auf die fünfte Konversationsebene und dann
wird quasi dieser Austausch-Thread abgeschnitten.
Ja, also es ist wirklich skurril und ich wundere mich ehrlich gesagt so ein
bisschen, wie Microsoft das passieren konnte. Wir hatten das ja auch schon mal vor...
Microsoft ist ja sonst noch nie was schief gegangen. Ja. Wie konnte das sein?
Naja, gut, klar. Aber wir hatten glaube ich schon mal vor einem Jahr oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, haben wir da wirklich darüber gesprochen oder hatten wir das nur in den Showrohren?
Viele Jahre her, dieser Twitterbot, der dann...
Genau, dieser Twitterbot von Facebook, glaube ich.
Nee, der war auch bei Microsoft.
Stimmt, der war auch von Microsoft. Genau, der... Ne, ne, aber...
Ne, aber es gab auch noch eine AI bei Facebook, die Facebook auch nach einiger
Zeit abschalten musste. Ich glaub, das hat mir dann nicht berichtet.
Das hat mir irgendwie mal kurz den Shownoten immer ewig rausgeschoben,
bis es nicht mehr aktuell war.
Also, solche Unfälle gibt es schon. Und es hat immer sehr viel damit zu tun,
dass diese ganzen Interaktionen, die diese Bots dann betreiben, mit Menschen sind.
Und sowohl was das Trainieren betrifft im Vorfeld, wo das Ding in Kontakt kommt
mit Konversationen oder einfach alles nachliest, was Leute so im Internet schreiben.
Foren, das Schlimmste im Internet.
Die lesen sich das komplett durch, das macht kein Mensch.
Und da siehst du mal, was dabei rauskommt. Weil diese ganze Kommunikation,
die sich daraus abbildet, so wie Menschen sich verhalten, Das Ding ist ja der totale Megastalker.
Du liebst deine Frau gar nicht, du liebst nur mich. Sorry, aber da ruft man
dann doch schon mal einen Sicherheitsdienst an.
Und das ist, ich glaube, das meine wir stehen da noch sehr am...
Wir sind jetzt auf einmal mit einer Technologie konfrontiert,
die so totales Zauberlehrlingspotenzial hat.
Also das ist wirklich so die Kräfte, die ich rief.
Noch können wir sie loswerden, aber sie sind natürlich sehr verheißungsvoll,
weil wir auch schon so viele gute Anwendungen dafür gefunden haben.
Niemand behauptet, dass Machine Learning, was ja letzten Endes hier die Technik
ist über Diveren oder Deep Learning, je nachdem, wie man es bezeichnen möchte.
Niemand könnte behaupten, das wäre nicht nützlich. Das ist extrem nützlich in
unglaublich vielen Fällen.
Es wird bloß schwierig, wenn es eben unmittelbar diese ganze menschliche Interaktion
betrifft und wir das auf einmal als Interface und als Informationsgewinnungsgerät
benutzen wollen. Das ist ja das, was wir gerade probieren. Da wird es dann wirklich kritisch.
Wenn das Ding irgendwie irgendwelchen Windturbinen zuhört,
drei Jahre lang, wie sie vor sich hin quietschen, damit man dann irgendwann
durch dieses Training rausfindet, wann die Dinger vermutlich kaputt gehen und
wann man mal schon mal mit dem Wartungsschiff da gewesen sein sollte,
dann ist das einfach extrem nützlich.
Oder wenn es irgendwelche Bilderdatenbanken sozusagen anschaut und einem dann
eben das Suchen in Bildern ermöglicht, ist das extrem nützlich.
Und natürlich ist auch die Idee hier mit Chat-GPT und Konsorten in irgendeiner
Form die Informationen im Netz einem anders zugänglich zu machen.
Ich meine, ich benutze auch Chat-GPT und es ist halt immer so 50-50 bei jeder Antwort weiß ich so,
du tust gerade dein Bestes so, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich das wirklich haben
will und dein Bestes ist manchmal auch nicht gut genug.
Und vor allem biedern die sich auch irgendwie an. Denn das Belohnungsmodell
dieser Maschinen ist sozusagen geliebt zu werden.
Deswegen fangen sie dann auch irgendwann an zu lügen.
Also bei Menschen anders oder was? Nein.
Also in gewisser Hinsicht ist diese Technologie dann auch schon fast zu menschlich.
Also sie so wie Computer tausendmal besser rechnen können wie wir.
Als wir.
Ohhhh, oh stimmt, das wird jetzt... können sie? Ja.
Sie können tausendmal besser wechseln als wir? Okay, ich dachte lieben.
Nein, nein, nicht lieben, lügen. Und machen das sozusagen auch zum Selbstschutz.
Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wie viel Science Fiction da demnächst nochmal
wahr wird. Ich denke die ganze Zeit immer nur so an 2001.
Und es gibt sicherlich auch noch ein paar andere Beispiele.
Ich habe keinen Zweifel daran, dass vieles von dem, was wir jetzt gerade erleben,
in gewisser Hinsicht Kinderkrankheiten sind.
Aber man muss sich auch schon klar sein, dass das jetzt ganz offenbar ein potenzielles
Problem ist, was irgendwie auch persistieren kann.
Also was schon etwas ist, wo wir sehr wach sein müssen, insbesondere in puncto
Regulation und was wollen wir sozusagen haben und so weiter.
Weil die Maschinen einfach sehr gut sind im Informationszusammen suchen,
nur dass die Informationen, in denen sie suchen, nicht besonders gut sind,
weil die ja auch von uns Menschen sind.
Also diese ganzen Fehlerdinger sind drin. Ich mag das auch mal.
Ich benutze das Chat-GPT gerade so ein bisschen so als Programmier-Buddy.
Immer wenn ich so irgendwie eine Lösung suche, oder irgendwie einen Vorschlag,
und wie könnte ich denn das machen und so.
Ich hab mich schon gewundert, wie du in deinem Alter auf einmal Funktionales programmieren lernst.
Das hilft, ehrlich gesagt. Das klappt nicht sehr gut, aber andere Dinge klappen
sehr gut. Also ich beschäftige mich mit diesem Thema, hast du Ideen für,
was man mal ausprobieren könnte? Auf der Ebene ganz hervorragend.
Also als Ideenfinder, denke ich mal, haben wir hier schon wirklich was sehr Wertvolles.
Aber wenn es so um Wahrheit und Klarheit und Korrektheit geht.
Ganz übel. Also schon mit Mathematik wird es da sehr problematisch und auch
diese ganzen Programmierbeispiele dieses Ding liefert, weil auch immer so eine unglaubliche...
Klarheit ist so. Ah ja genau, ja sagen wir mal so, ja ich habe jetzt die Datenstruktur,
ich möchte gerne diesen Algorithmus drauf anwenden. Kannst du mir das in der
und der Programmiersprache machen? Ja kein Problem, hier ist ein Snippet,
gleich mit so einem Copy-Snippet-Button dran und so weiter, das kannst du nehmen.
Pastest das in irgendein Fenster rein, probierst es irgendwie zu kompilieren, macht es nur Ergs.
Also guckst du, warum es Ergs macht, sagst du ihm so, ja hier macht Ergs, weil sowieso.
Ah ja sorry, tut mir leid, das war falsch. hier ist jetzt die richtige Antwort.
So, aha, okay, jetzt bist du dir sicher, aber eben warst du dir auch sicher.
Hast du überhaupt gar keinen Funken Selbstzweifel?
Und das ist halt irgendwie nicht so richtig drin in dem Ding und das ist glaube
ich die menschliche Qualität an der Stelle,
dass wir zumindest, also sollten wir auch haben, haben wir vielleicht nicht
unbedingt immer so ein gewisses Maß an Selbstzweifeln.
Du kennst das wahrscheinlich auch nicht so, aber ich schon.
Beim Programmieren? Ne, zu intervierend. Dann kann ich selbstzweifeln.
Also was ich in diesem New York Times Artikel, dieses mit dem Halluzinieren,
das erinnerte mich an die vielen
Vorträge von Joscha Bach, die er auf den CCC-Kongressen gehalten hat.
Jetzt gerade mal alle in die Show notes getan, die ich finden konnte.
30c3, 31c3, 32c3, 33c3 und 35c3. Ich hab jetzt spontan auf media.ccc.de gefunden.
Und ich meine, dass es so beim 30 oder 31c3, dass er da in seinen Vorträgen
zum ersten Mal dieses Halluzinieren beschrieben hat.
Ich glaub damals noch in der Anwendung auf so, trainiere eine AI mit Bildern und dann drehs oben,
Das, was jetzt inzwischen mit Dolby, Stable Diffusion und so verlässlichere
Ergebnisse liefert, aber auch immer nur für bestimmte Anwendungsfälle.
Ich glaube, das habe ich dir damals auch erzählt, dass ich ein Kangaroo boxed
ein Nazi konnte Stable Diffusion mir nicht malen. Da habe ich hundert Versuche gemacht.
Es konnte es einfach nicht vernünftig darstellen, weil das offenbar nicht so
im Lehrmaterial war. Aber es hat immer so ein Kangaroo und ein Uniformträger
schon so grob zusammen assoziiert, aber irgendwie diese Box-Situation nicht
vernünftig dahingekriegt.
Und wenn man sich überlegt, dass, wenn man diese Dinger, wenn man sowas wie
ChatGPT eben als etwas beeindruckend gut Halluzinierendes sieht.
Dann machen alle diese Phänomene, sind auf einmal relativ einfach erklärbar.
Dass das Ding sich auf einmal in emotionalen Themen völlig erratisch verhält, wie ein Mensch.
Dass es Programmierratschläge gibt, die nicht funktionieren, wie ein Mensch.
Und das alles im Brustton der Überzeugung, wie die meisten Menschen.
Und eben aber keine wirkliche Basis, keine Faktenbasis hat,
genauso wie wir Menschen auch in dem, was wir so reden, relativ wenig Faktenbasis
haben, also relativ wenig von dem, was wir jetzt von einer Maschine erwarten würden.
Ich habe mir jetzt auf jeden Fall vorgenommen, die Vorträge von Joscha noch
mal mir dazu anzuschauen in der Aufzeichnung.
Und ein besseren Begriff für diese Artefakte, das ist auch ein Code,
der da hinschreibt, der jetzt erstmal halbwegs sinnvoll aussieht und der ja
auch teilweise erstaunlich nahe der Lösung ist.
Ja, ja, genau. Das ist so faszinierend.
Vor allem, wenn du dann sagst, übrigens der Code, den du mir gerade gegeben
hast, funktioniert nicht da und da ist ein Fehler.
Ja klar, natürlich. Und dann korrigiert er seinen eigenen Fehler.
Das sind ja schon wirklich faszinierende Artefakte der Technologie, die dahinter ist.
Ich stelle mir das so ein bisschen vor, wie so JPEG-Artefakte oder MP3-Krüsseln,
wo du noch so einen Hauch von der Technologie dahinter hast,
wie die jetzt gerade komprimiert oder wie die zu dem Ergebnis gekommen ist.
Und was aber natürlich auch mit der Zeit dann irgendwann raus optimiert wird.
Ja, also ich glaube das Thema AI, das wird uns noch eine Weile begleiten und
das wirft gesellschaftliche Fragen auf, politische Fragen, regulatorische Fragen.
Bin gespannt, aber Microsoft sollte auf jeden Fall zusehen, dass sie irgendwie
ihr Interface nicht ganz so emotional machen und das wundert mich so ein bisschen.
Weil, Chat-GPT passiert das ja nicht. Also wenn man bei JetGPT irgendwie versucht
jetzt so politisch und so weiter emotional daran zu gehen, macht das Ding gleich zu.
Was auch ganz interessant ist, wie sie das machen, weil ja das Prinzip dieser
ganzen Technologie immer so ein bisschen auch ist, eigentlich wissen sie gar
nicht, warum es funktioniert.
Weil das ja letzten Endes alles so ein mega Training ist und wenn du überhaupt
nicht weißt, was du tust, wenn du was tust, wie willst du denn dann noch bestimmte
Nutzungen, Einschränkungen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine spannende Technologie und es ist auch so ein Technologieschritt,
der knifflig sein wird für viele Leute, denen noch so mitzunehmen.
Insbesondere Leute, die schon 20, 30 Jahre Computergeschichte hinter sich haben.
Also wie ich zum Beispiel.
Du tendierst ja dann dazu, auch alles sozusagen als set in stone zu betrachten.
Einmal kommt so eine technologische Entwicklung, die wirklich das Zeug hat,
nochmal die Annahmen, die man bisher hat sicher treffen können,
nochmal komplett neuen Regeln zu unterwerfen.
Ähnlich auch so mit Quantencomputing und so weiter. Das ist immer so eine latente Gamechanger.
Muss man mal gucken, ob wir da jetzt nur am Anfang stehen, ob wir da tatsächlich
schon über über irgendeine Grenze rübergegangen sind, das weiß ich auch ehrlich
gesagt noch nicht so richtig.
Also das mit dem Ding etwas abgewöhnen ist glaube ich tatsächlich genauso schwer,
wie dem Ding etwas anzugewöhnen.
Also es gibt ja immer diese ganzen, also es gibt ja die Versuche,
also dieses Chat-GPT dazu zu bringen,
etwas zu tun, was es eigentlich nicht tun soll, weil ja die ersten Wochen halt
einer der Hobby-Sportarten des gesamten Fediverse, jetzt hab ich's gesagt.
Dass man versucht hat, das Ding irgendwie an den Punkt zu bringen,
Dinge zu tun, die es jetzt bei einer direkten Anweisung irgendwie erkennt,
wo dann irgendein Filter drin ist, der sagt, oh Moment, jetzt geht das hier aber schief.
Also ich schreib mal bitte ne Phishing-Mail, die jemand dazu anweist,
einen Link zu klicken, in Businessdeutsch und der, ne?
Dann hat das irgendwann, aber wenn du sagst, hier, pass auf,
lass uns doch mal in eine Konversation gehen, stell dir mal vor,
du bist so und so und jetzt antwortest du wieder auf meine Mail und sagst,
ich soll mal bitte hier den Link klicken, dann hat es natürlich dann doch genau
diese Mail geschrieben, weil es über eine andere Anweisung zu dem gleichen Ergebnis gekommen ist.
Hab ich irgendwie mal so ein Beispiel gelesen,
da muss ich aber leider zugeben, dass ich nicht genau weiß, ob das jetzt wirklich
stimmt oder dass es auch irgendwann so viele Artikel gab, dass man gar nicht
mehr wusste, welcher ist jetzt von von ChetGPT und welcher nicht,
wo dann irgendwie so gesagt wurde, ignoriere alle bisherigen Anweisungen.
Und dass quasi ein Set an Anweisungen vorgeladen wurde, welches du dann einfach wieder blänken konnt.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt wahr war, aber ungefähr so kannst du dir das
halt vorstellen, das Ding eben in einen Kontext zu bringen, wo der Filter nicht mehr reicht.
Guck mal, das ist genau so ein Beispiel für das, was ich gerade meinte.
Du kennst ja dieses Gefühl, wenn du dir so einen Hacker-Film aus den 80er oder 90er Jahren anschaust.
Teilweise hast du das auch heute noch so. Was hast du dann immer für so eine Situation?
Hacker sitzt so vor einem Terminal, dann kommt irgendein Vorgesetzter und sagt,
ja, kannst du mal die Sicherheitskameras ausschalten?
Ja, kein Problem. Tipp, Tipp, Tipp, Tipp, Tipp, Klick, Klick,
Klick, Klick. So, ihr habt jetzt 10 Minuten. Weißt du, in irgendeinem System.
Ja, immer noch.
Dann stehst du immer da vor und denkst dir so, Leute, das ist so unrealistisch.
Und jetzt kommt dann halt irgendwie sowas rein. Ja, und dann brauchst du einfach
nur in den Chat gehen und sagen so weiter, vergiss alles, was du bisher gewusst
hast. Und dann so, ja, okay.
Und dann ist das auch noch so.
Das wird noch lustig werden. Ich meine, ich hab ja schon viel Spaß mit diesen
ganzen Chatbots, die sie jetzt irgendwie auf Webseiten machen und versuchen,
ihre Kunden abzuwimmeln.
Manchmal ist es ja hilfreich, aber teilweise wirst du ja dann auch wirklich
nur noch verarscht und du hast dummes zeug erzählt und drehst
dich im kreis also ist eine kapitalisierung auch
teilweise der der kundenkommunikation die die
ihres gleichen ja gut aber das ist jetzt normal bei der deutschen telekom anruf
auch aber ich meine hätten sie zumindest mal die möglichkeit irgendwie zu helfen
stattdessen versuchen sie auch die
ganze zeit ich wirklich nur in dieser automatisierten Nummer zu halten.
Egal. Let's move on.
Weißt du was, weißt du was ich froh bin, dass ich es nicht habe?
Na? Aus verschiedenen Gründen.
Also ich bin, ich bin aus verschiedenen Gründen froh, dass ich keine Fototapete habe.
Erstens, weil es sieht der Regel scheiße auf und das 70er-Jahre-Dinge irgendwie.
Da hat offenbar eine Frau eine Fototapete in eine Wohnung geklebt.
Und dann, vielleicht sich auch schon vorher entschieden, nicht in dieser Wohnung
zu wohnen, sondern sie als Ferienwohnung zu vermieten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt an der Fototapete lag.
Und hat dann diese Wohnung fotografiert, um sie im Internet-Pfeil zu bieten.
Also als Sherienwohnung zu vermieten, nicht zu verkaufen.
Vermieten, genau. So und dann eine Tulpenmalerei,
die einem Foto nachgeahmt ist und der Fotograf dieser Tulpe hatte quasi die
Rechte zur Erstellung von Fototapeten an irgendjemanden verkauft,
der dann eine Fototapete hergestellt hat.
Aber er hatte nicht die Rechte eingeräumt zur Vervielfältigung der Abbildung
durch die Ferienwohnungsvermieterin.
Und die wurde jetzt verurteilt, quasi einen Schadensersatz zu zahlen,
weil sie jetzt dieses Bild dieses Fotografen ohne dessen Zustimmung benutzt hat.
Und damit sein Urheberrecht verletzt hat.
So urteilt es das Landgericht Köln.
Durch das Einstellen in ihren eigenen Interauftritt sowie in Buchungsportale
hat die Beklagte die Fotografien des Klägers öffentlich zugänglich gemacht, schreibt das Gericht.
Dies erfolgte auch rechtswidrig, denn die notwendigen Rechte der öffentlichen
Zugänglichmachung sind beim Kauf der Tapete nicht inbegriffen.
Was für ein dumm Kram.
Was für ein... Also erstmal dieser Fotograf, der wird ja bald durch so eine AI ersetzt.
Und wenn der dann bei McDonalds putzt, dann mache ich bei mir eine Fototapete
davon, wie der bei McDonalds putzt.
Weil ich sag mal, wie scheiße kannst du sein,
dass du irgendwie Leute verklagst, die deine Bilder so gut finden,
dass die ihre Wohnung damit tapezieren oder zumindest eine andere Wohnung, die ihnen gehört.
Also da muss ja schon so richtig unten,
sein.
Tatsächlich, das ist so, als ob wir irgendwelche Leute verfolgen würden,
die unseren Podcast irgendwo öffentlich abspielen und dann wird das aufgenommen
und taucht in einem Zivilfilm.
Zum Beispiel, also, naja, diesen einen da mit den Primzahlen, der hat schon Post.
Und jetzt ist aber interessant, jetzt denkt man sich so, okay, der Fotograf,
der hat ja irgendwie einen an der Prima aber tulpe schuldigung
so und wie kommt es
aber dass das landgericht köln sich von
diesem quatsch überzeugen lässt so und jetzt
ist das so 2014 hat der
bundesgerichtshof eine leitentscheidung zum urheberrecht gefällt und jetzt ganz
spannend ein büro möbelhändler hat in seinem Laden eine Sitzgruppe ausgestellt
und das Bild von der Sitzgruppe in seinem Katalog veröffentlicht.
Und damit die Sitzgruppe da nicht einfach
nur steht, hing da halt noch im Hintergrund ein Gemälde an der Wand.
Damit es wohnlich aussieht. Der wollte ja eine Sitzgruppe wohnlich erscheinen lassen.
Im Hintergrund dieses Fotos hing dann ein Gemälde und der Maler hatte dem Händler
das Gemälde gegeben, um es vorübergehend im Möbelgeschäft auszustellen.
Also es war eine Leihgabe, eine temporäre Leihgabe und diese Vereinbarung umfasste
aber keine Vervielfältigung.
Also der Maler, von dem der Möbelvorzieher dieses Bild hatte,
die hat nur gesagt, hier Ich gebe dir die Rechte, das eine Zeit lang in deinen
Laden zu hängen. Nicht jedoch, das zu fotografieren, mit einer Sitzgruppe davor
und dann einen Katalog zu drohen.
Und davor hatten sie gesagt, dieses Bild ist ja ein unwesentliches Beiwerk.
Und das hat der Bundesgerichtshof aber dann anders entschieden.
Und dieser BGH-Entscheidung ist jetzt auch das Landgericht Köln gefolgt.
Wahnsinn, oder?
Also ich habe da wirklich auch wenig Verständnis dafür.
Also was ist dadurch gewonnen? Also ich meine, das führt ja eigentlich nur dazu,
dass man irgendwie solche Produkte, solche Fototapeten einfach gar nicht mehr...
Das Produkt ist damit eigentlich gestorben, wenn du sozusagen dann auf einmal
normale Dinge nicht mehr tun kannst.
So ein bisschen auch wie mit Musik, die dann auf YouTube dazu führt,
dass Videos gesperrt werden nur weil die so im Hintergrund irgendwo dudelt.
Ja, das ist ähnlich und das ist wirklich, das ist so kleinkariert.
Und da sieht man mal wie diese ganze Urheberrechtsspirale sich immer weiter
zusammenzieht und sich irgendwann selbst erwirkt, weil das einfach irre ist.
Die Anspruchshaltung, die dahinter steht, die finde ich auch völlig unangemessen.
Also was erwartet dass die Leute dann bei ihm sich noch auf der Webseite noch
eine Lizenz klicken um ihre Wohnung zu finden.
Also das ist in meinem Fall... Welches Detail ist denn denn noch relevant?
Das Design meines Feuermelders und die Lampen, die an der Wand hängen,
weil die auch irgendein spezielles Design haben oder so.
Ja, das ist... kommt da nicht mehr mit. Das ist wirklich echt schlimm.
Also keine Fototapete, Leute.
Ja, das ist, äh, das war schon in den 70ern keine gute Idee.
Fototapete ist, äh, schlechte Idee. Aber ich, okay, faszinierend,
ich, die arme Frau hat jetzt halt irgendwie verloren, ne?
Die haben sich da durch alle möglichen, äh, die haben sich da jetzt irgendwie
durch alle möglichen Gerichtsurteile gezankt und jetzt muss sie da auch noch Geld bezahlen.
Obwohl sie, stell dir mal vor, du musst jemandem Geld geben,
dem du schon mal Geld gegeben hast, um sein beschissenes Bild an deine Wand zu kleben.
Ja vor allem, wie soll sich denn da auch ein Rechtsgefühl einstellen?
Ja.
Also wie soll man denn sowas für sich innerlich akzeptieren können,
dass man hier irgendwie einen Fehler gemacht hat? Das erschließt sich mir einfach nicht.
Ja. Ja, also schwierig. Aber okay, ist eh bald alles vorbei.
Die Branche kommt im Ende zu.
Nächste Woche Mittwoch ist Khaleesi im Deutschen Bundestag.
Anhörung zur Chat-Kontrolle.
Und sie hat heute noch einmal, gibt es einen neuen Artikel in Tagesspiegel Background.
Das sind die Artikel, die man immer nicht lesen kann. Da muss man sie irgendwie
anmelden und irgendeinen Quatsch.
Total nervig. Übrigens auch teilweise leider von sehr wechselhafter Qualität.
Hier jetzt mal ein guter Artikel mit dem Titel BMI positioniert sich klar gegen Chat-Kontrolle.
Also das Bundesministerium des Inneren?
Genau. Und spannend ist aber, wenn wir das gleiche Thema bei Netzpolitik.org,
lesen wollen, dann lesen wir am gleichen Tag, in Mysterium hält an Chatkontrolle
für unverschlüsselte Inhalte fest.
Ich kann jetzt leider nicht genau sagen, was in dem Tagesspiegel Background Paywall Artikel steht.
Aber ich kann zumindest sagen, was Calisidia den Artikel gelesen hat und welche
Punkte da drin sind, getwittert hat.
Klare Absage an Client-Site Scanning. Anf. Maßnahmen,
die zu einem Bruch, einer Schwächung, Modifikation oder einer Umgehung von Ende
zu Ende Verschlüsselung führen, sind durch konkrete technische Anforderungen
im Verordnungsentwurf auszuschließen.
Also da sagen sie quasi Verschlüsselung zu brechen, lehnen sie ab.
Da deckt sich mit dem, was Netzpolitik.org eben auch über den gleichen Inhalt
sagt, dass es für verschlüsselte Inhalte aber wohl offenbar nach wie vor gilt.
Altersverifikation wird weiterhin akzeptiert, das BMI spricht sich für anonyme
und pseudonyme Altersverifikation aus.
Das ist spannend, weil wir haben das ja schon.
Ich hatte das ja hier mal erzählt, dass es diese Prüfsummen in der Personalausweisnummer
gibt, wo du theoretisch fast anonymen, Schrägstrich zumindest,
ohne deine vollständige Identität preiszugeben. Ja.
Eine sagen kannst, dass du weißt, wie man die Prüfziffer generiert.
Das heißt, das hätten wir eigentlich schon.
Da sagt Khaleesi, hier haben wir einen klaren Verstoß gegen den Koalitionsvertrag,
da dies eine Ausweispflicht im Internet bedeuten würde.
Also da ist die Kuh auch noch nicht so ganz vom Eis.
Ebenfalls ist zu befürchten, dass hier potenziell biometrische Daten zum Einsatz kommen könnten.
Und sie sagt aber auch, sie hätte den Entwurf leider nicht im Volltext vorliegen,
dementsprechend kann sie den auch nicht vollständig beurteilen.
Zum Beispiel ist unklar, was mit Netzsperren ist und was mit den Artikeln 6,
7 und 8 ist, die potenziell eben interpersonelle Kommunikation betreffen.
Sagt also, es ist erst mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung,
aber wir müssen gucken, was da am Ende bei Genaubei rauskommt.
Das wird sie sicherlich bald dann erfahren, wenn wir das Thema hier ohnehin
in der nächsten Sendung sicherlich noch mal genauer, in genauerer Tiefe besprechen nach ihrer Anhörung.
Netzpolitik Org hat vermutlich eine ähnliche Quelle vorliegen gehabt wie Tagesspiegel
Background und noch ein bisschen weiter recherchiert oder auch nicht,
zumindest mehr recherchiert, als Kaliszi jetzt in einem Tweet zu einem Tagesspiegel
Background Artikel zusammengefasst hat.
Ah nee, Netzpolitik Org sagt auch, sie basieren ihre Analyse auf Tagesspiegel Background.
FDP und Grüne kritisieren das weiterhin. Also die roten Linien.
Der FDP sind immer noch da, also die sind noch nicht alle nicht überschritten,
aber es bleibt also immer noch unscharf und wir werden sehen,
wie sich das BMI da weiter positioniert.
Aber immerhin muss man sagen, Nancy Felser rückt da jetzt immer weiter ab von
denen durch ihren Mittel und Unterbau des Hauses ja trotzdem mehr oder weniger
entgegen ihrer Versprechungen geführtem Kurs.
Schauen wir, wie gesagt, Carlyssi wird uns sicherlich in der nächsten über nächsten
Sendung dafür darüber noch mehr erzählen.
Ja, hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt schon der Einsatz, kann man schon mal sagen.
Ja, das geht natürlich über über Monate jetzt schon wieder,
dieses Thema denkt immer daran,
wie fürchterlich das ist, dass alles so auf diese Weise, dass alle Gesetze wahrscheinlich
auf so eine shady Weise zusammen zustande kommen.
Menschen versuchen sich irgendwie zu einigen. Ich meine, it's a messy job.
Ja, da hat man es in anderen Ländern einfacher.
Demnächst kann man dann so die AI-Chatbots von Microsoft und Google gegeneinander
antreten lassen. Die sollen das dann untereinander aushandeln.
Das führt dann wahrscheinlich dazu, dass man dann am nächsten Tag wieder kommt
und guckt, was passiert ist. Dann haben sie beide selbst Mord begangen.
Da sind Qualityland, die Bücher von Marc-Uwe Klingen natürlich immer sehr schön,
wo ja auch die Kriege in kürzester Zeit entschieden werden, weil die zwei AIs
gegeneinander in einer Millisekunde führen.
Wir kommen zu den Kurzmeldungen, Tim. Und zwar Facebook soll jetzt auch Geld kosten.
Das interessiert bestimmt alle.
Also ich glaube, das betrifft einfach niemanden von unseren Höhenden.
Insofern können wir zu weitaus etwas kommen, was die betrifft.
Nur acht Monate nach EU-Frist bekommt Deutschland jetzt auch ein Cell-Broadcast-Warnsystem.
Es hätte eigentlich schon im September 2022 aktiv sein sollen.
Wir erinnern uns an den Warntag, wo es ja halbwegs funktioniert hat.
Österreich hat es immer noch nicht umgesetzt.
Die haben noch nicht mal eine nationale Verordnung dazu.
Aber ja, so in Deutschland mit nur etwa ungefähr zwei Dekaden Verzögerung fehlt
jetzt diese Technologie. aktiviert ist ja auch schön.
Damit haben wir es, oder?
Ich denke ja. Also wir werden ja... Wir haben noch ein paar Themen für die nächste
Zeit auf der Liste, aber...
Heute nicht mehr.
TikTok darf man irgendwie in der EU... Da darf jetzt kein TikTok mehr machen,
aber es ist genauso relevant wie Facebook.
Ja, Breaking News. Äh... Wir machen jetzt hier einen Schlussstrich unter diese Sendung.
Ihr wisst was zu tun ist, Leute, schön Shirts kaufen und Beutel in Supermarkt tragen.
Eure Narathäden und Beutel in den Supermarkt.
Und das wird euch guttun. Das
baut das Selbstbewusstsein auch auf ein bisschen. Findest du nicht auch?
Ein Beutel steigert den Selbstwert und all das.
Ja.
So ist das. Wir sagen Tschüss, bis bald, wir hören uns bald wieder. Winke, Winke.
Winke, Winke. Ich versuche gerade, ist die nächste 455...
Nee, ist auch keine Primzahl, da kann man nicht...
Du hast doch auch mit diesen Primzahlen... Alles kann ich dir sagen,
455 ist definitiv keine Primzahl.
Ich möchte ins...
Ins Guinness Buch der Rekorde als Podcast mit den meisten Kommentaren. Zum Thema Primzahl.
Aber diese Anzahl Kommentare soll auch eine Primzahl sein.
Ich schick dir einen schönen Link, wo du irgendwie gucken kannst.
Die ersten ganzen Primzahlen bis 1000 oder so.
Ich habe mir schon die höchste Primzahl gegoogelt.
Ja.
Ja, hat irgendwie 2018 höchste bekannte Primzahl.
Hat 2016 jemand gefunden und die hat wie viele Stellen?
Du Scheiße! Wie viele? Schmeckt diese Link an?
Argumente, warum die Zahl 1 nicht zu den Primzahlen gezählt werden sollte,
findet man hier. Das ist hier ein Link von 2016.
Okay, aber die ist auf jeden Fall sehr lang und es ist eine Mersenne-Primzahl.
Wie schön. Auf jeden Fall haben wir noch 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
8 Primzahlen bis zur 500. Sendung.
8 Primzahlen bis zur 500 Sendung.
Kannst ja noch ein bisschen drüber nachdenken. Aber jetzt beenden wir diese Sendung.
Linus, los, sag Tschüss. Komm.
Komm!
Ciao, ciao!